hey everyone it's Mike from mot fla and
welcome back to my channel you know it's
been a while since I posted a video I
was uh I was a little busy over the last
month but uh hopefully I get back into
the swing of cranking out some
educational videos for you guys and you
know today's video topic sort of comes
on the back of a a comment that I saw on
one of my earlier videos about uh trap
Traders and and how to take advantage of
them and basically it comes down to
understanding the different types of
trading that's taking place now before I
jump in you know if if you enjoy my
videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel hit the Subscribe button if you
haven't already um you know we keep
growing every day adding a lot of
subscribers and you know if you got an
interesting comment be sure to leave it
down below I I do look at the comments I
don't often have time to reply to every
single one but I do uh check into them
time to time all right so again you know
trap Traders is a term that you know a
lot of people use you know I see people
using them on uh charts you know a bar
chart oh there's trap Traders here and
and you but really you can't really tell
on in my opinion on a bar chart okay but
if you're looking on a footprint chart
whoops wrong chart it's a little bit
easier to see and generally when you see
trap Traders um you're not going to see
volume on the other side and what do I
mean by that okay so for example down
here at this at this little swing low
you see volume coming down into low 199
7426 but nothing on the offer side 00 0
okay are these Traders tra well probably
you know probably a big seller just came
down here swept the market down to uh 8
and a qu and then immediately it just
immediately bounced back and S of the
comment that I saw is how can you say
there was buying taking place down here
because it's it's selling right there's
no buying 0000 0 well you don't
understand how the 2A auction works
because you what you have is different
types of buying and selling but you have
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
you have passive buying and passive
selling
so the people that sold down here at 8
and a quter that sold 26 Lots well who'
they sell it to they didn't sell it into
thin air they sold it to passive buyers
so there was buying taking place but you
have zero here zero here there just
wasn't aggressive buying taking place
right that's why it's zero and zero here
so basically what happened is you know
there big order just went through the
market just hit everything down there
once that order got filled completed
Market immediately bounced back right
and it started trading back back up at
at 09 and the best way to describe uh
passive Traders is by looking at the
depth of Market the dome right price
Dome price ladder you know people got
different terms for it so here we are
okay and you'll see there's
bids and there's offers okay so Market's
currently uh 99 3/4 bid at uh 52
even the people are trying to buy it at
on the bid these are passive buyers
people are trying to buy it below the
bid are passive buyers
people that are trying to sell it on the
offer and above are passive
sellers okay so you know the 26 that got
sold here the 74 that got sold here the
199 it got sold into bids passive buyers
resting liquidity in the market that's
down here right cuz again you know right
now we're trading around 98 and 3/4 but
there's bids in the market right at 97
97 and A4 97 and a half for these bids
to trade for these passive buyers to get
filled you're going to need an
aggressive seller to come in and clear
out the 98 3/4 98 half 984
98s 97 3/4 down to you know 9750 and and
and below for these passive buyers to
get filled now they may never get filled
you know that's the difference between a
limit order right or a bid below the
market is there's no guarantee you're
going to get filled you're only going to
get guaranteed to fill if you you trade
at the market you hit the bid or lift
the offer just as these offers above the
market these are passive sellers okay
you know if the market you know right
now we're trading 98 and a quarter but
if gets back up to 52 even you know
there's 102 Lots there at 52 and a half
there's
114 okay it doesn't mean it's going to
trade there but these are passive
sellers so when you see the volume like
this right 26 74 199 but 0 doesn't
doesn't mean there's no buying just
means that there's no aggressive buying
taking place when you see volume on the
offer side trades it is aggressive
buyers coming into the market when you
see volume on the bid side um that means
there was aggressive sellers in the
market aggressive sellers sell to
passive buyers passive buyers sorry
aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers right then what causes the
market to go up is the aggressive buyers
are lifting lifting the offers clearing
it out to the next offer to the next
offer just as if a market is going down
it's people selling into the bid
clearing that out selling into the next
bid okay and sometimes you get a push
down right a little sweep just a big
order comes down and sweeps over the
order book once that's done Market sort
of bounces back to where it was before
like right here and you know same thing
would be true on the offer side you can
see here Zer Zer but 71 trade on the
offer 14 trade on the offer that doesn't
I mean there was no buying you can't you
know for every buy buyer there's a
seller okay it's just whether it's
aggressive buyer or aggressive seller or
um you know just keep this in mind
aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers passive buyers buy from
aggressive
sellers so even though there's no
aggressive selling here this is Euro
currency at you know at uh what is that
10888 10887 A2 that doesn't mean there
was no selling taking place there was
there was limit orders here at 88 there
was limit orders here at 87 A5
aggressive buyers bought from those
passive sellers think of it this way
okay understanding aggressive buyers and
aggressive
sellers okay this is uh realtor.com just
looking at houses so for example right
this beautiful house here 2 point well
no better better one here big one um
crazy price
five it's insane 5,
999,000 um even okay so just under $6
million he is a passive seller at 5.9
million okay if I had the money and I
want to buy this house because I'm so in
love with this house I want to buy it
right I would pay what he's trying to
sell it at I he's the passive seller I'm
the aggressive a buyer because I want
this house now you'll notice right he
dropped the price by
$51,000 so actually this house
66.5 million but he's lowering it down
now he's starting to get a little bit
aggressive looking for a bid in the
market right he's checking you know
maybe I I could lower my offer from up
here down to where I think the market is
Right join still joining the offer now
if somebody came in in it's like you
know what I like this
house but I don't think it's worth 5.9
million I think maybe it's worth 5.5
million so what that buyer would do he
doesn't think it's worth 5.9 so he's not
going to be aggressive and pay 5.9 he's
going to bid 5 A5 million right he's
going to join the bid here at
5.5 so the house is not going to sell
because I have a buyer at 5.5 where I've
got the seller at
5.9 so either for this house to trade or
get sold the seller would have to go
down and hit that bid at 55 million or
the buyer would have to go up and lift
the offer at 5.9 okay that's the
difference between aggressive buying and
aggressive
selling okay sometimes it it gets lost
in the market cuz people just see the
volumes that go through right they just
see oh you know it traded here at at uh
88 traded here at 87 A5 okay and then
they see the zero here and they think
well there was no trade there okay so
there was no buying taking place or
sorry no selling taking place at 87 and
A5 well actually there was it was on the
offer it was a passive seller that was
selling to an aggressive buyer
just like down here right you had limits
in the market right just like right the
house
5 n but in this case you know Market's
5208 you know at this point it was
trading a little higher
529 but there was a seller came in here
and hit the bid hit the bid hit the bid
he was aggressive
seller selling into passive buyer so
passive buyers bought down here
okay that's the difference between
aggressive
buying and passive buying right if if
there was aggressive buying taking place
you would see volume here on the offer
at 8 and a half volume on the offer at 8
and 3/4 but there
wasn't okay you just had passive buying
taking place from aggressive sellers
right an aggressive seller remember
aggressive seller sells at the market
they hit the bids aggressive buyers buy
at the market they lift the
offers so that's going to end it on this
video of understanding sort of the
difference between aggressive buying and
aggressive selling as well as passive
buying and passive selling because
remember right it's not people aren't
selling it Into Thin Air they're selling
it into a bid or they're buying it from
an offer right the liquidity in the
market um think of you know there's
people that provide liquidity think of
it this way get back to our Dome real
quick these people are providing
liquidity the passive buyers the passive
sellers are providing liquidity right
it's the people that buy at the market
are removing that liquidity people that
sell at the market are removing that
liquidity all right guys so that will
end it on this video again you know if
you haven't already be sure to subscribe
to the channel hit that like button as
well as uh you know if you got any uh
comments be sure to leave them down
there in the comment section all right
everyone I'll catch you guys on the next
video take
care